No en ningún secreto: en los países más
ricos cada vez son menos las personas que
quieren tener hijos. La caída de la natalidad
es prácticamente un fenómeno generalizado
en todo el mundo desarrollado. Parece claro
que va a convertirse en uno de los mayores
retos en un futuro muy próximo: hablamos
de países cada vez más envejecidos y con
menos niños.
De hecho, la mayoría de los países desarrollados
ya están muy por debajo de la tasa de reemplazo.
Es decir, por debajo de los 2,1 hijos por
mujer en edad fértil que harían falta para
que, al menos, la población se mantuviera
estable, sin contar, claro está, la inmigración.
Sin embargo, hay un caso concreto, un país
en el que ya no es que la gente tenga de media
menos de dos hijos por mujeres, ¡Es que ni
siquiera llegan a uno! Hablamos del país
con menos natalidad de todo el mundo.
Y sí, como ya os habréis imaginado, aunque
solo sea por el Thumbnail y el título de
este vídeo, estoy hablando de Corea del Sur.
Fijaos.
Concretamente, hablamos de un índice de fecundidad
de solo 0,78 hijos por mujer en 2022. Un nivel
tan bajo que casi que podríamos decir que
en Corea tener niños se ha convertido en
toda una anomalía. Y, ojo, porque en Seúl
esta tasa todavía es peor, agarraos a la
silla, hablamos de tan solo 0,59 hijos por
mujer. Casi una cuarta parte que la tasa de
reemplazo.
Es decir, que en este caso no es que Corea
del Sur esté atravesando un invierno demográfico,
es que prácticamente estamos ante la crónica
de una extinción anunciada.
(A pesar de ser uno de los países más ricos
y avanzados del mundo, Corea del Sur se enfrenta
a un problema colosal cuya solución no resulta
nada fácil y que podría provocar una catástrofe
demográfica en este país como nunca antes
se haya visto.
Una catástrofe demográfica y, de no cambiar
las cosas, quizás también económica. Y
es que, incluso, aun contando con la fuerte
robotización de la industria, de seguir así
las cosas, es posible que en poco tiempo no
haya trabajadores suficientes como para mantener
en marcha su economía: sus fábricas, sus
comercios, sus colegios y los negocios de
todo tipo.)
Y no, no estamos exagerando. Para nada. Fijaos
un momento en este gráfico:
¿Os dais cuenta de lo que esto significa?
Lo que estáis viendo es la proyección de
la población de Corea del Sur durante las
próximas décadas. Como podéis ver, a día
de hoy el país de la mañana tranquila ya
habría alcanzado su máximo histórico de
población.
A partir de ahora su población no solo será
mucho más anciana, sino que, además, comenzará
a perder población. Y no penséis que lo
hará lentamente. En los próximos 40 años
este país perderá más de 12 millones de
habitantes, un 25% de toda su población.
Lo que en términos demográficos es una salvajada.
Y eso no es todo. Para finales de siglo, de
seguir la tendencia actual, se espera que
la población surcoreana se reduzca a menos
de la mitad. De casi 52 millones de habitantes
hoy a poco más de 20. No hay ningún otro
país en todo el mundo con unas previsiones
tan malas.
Hablamos de un escenario en el que no solo
los surcoreanos pueden terminar desapareciendo,
sino que además en el proceso podría destruirse
tanta riqueza que los que vayan quedando se
enfrentarán a enormes dificultades.
(Pensadlo bien, si las previsiones se cumplen,
muchos de los niños que están naciendo hoy
verán a su país con la mitad de población
cuando se jubilen, con todo lo que ello implica:
Más gasto social, menos ahorro, menos consumo,
etcétera, etcétera. Y, ojo, que no hablamos
de una hipótesis remota, sino de un proceso
que ya se ha puesto en marcha. Tras años
con la tasa de natalidad absolutamente hundida,
en el país ya hay muchos casos, de escuelas
primarias, hospitales y servicios obstétricos
y pediátricos que están teniendo que echar
el cierre.)
Ahora bien, puede que llegados a este punto
muchos os estéis preguntando… ¿Por qué
diablos está pasando esto en un país donde
supuestamente la economía va viento en popa
y a la gente no le falta de nada? ¿Cuáles
son exactamente los motivos por los que los
surcoreanos ya no quieren tener hijos? ¿Qué
está haciendo el Estado para revertir esta
situación? ¿Tiene acaso alguna solución?
Pues bien, en este vídeo os vamos a responder
a estas y más preguntas, así que… Atentos,
porque esta es la historia del país que está
corriendo hacía su propia extinción.
T1(LOS CUATRO ‘NOES’)
Como os podéis imaginar, un desastre como
este que os estamos contando no es algo que
ocurra porque sí. Hay motivos, y no son,
precisamente, pocos ni fáciles de explicar.
Pero aquí en VisualPolitik os lo vamos a
tratar de contar de la forma más sintetizada
posible.
Y es que, veréis, lo más fácil sería culpar
a los salarios bajos, la hiper-competitividad
profesional q ue hay en Corea o a que las
mujeres prefieren centrarse en sus carreras
antes que ponerlas en riesgo para tener hijos.
Pero… No, aunque estos factores tienen parte
de la culpa, no nos sirven para explicar por
qué Corea es el país con menos natalidad
del mundo. Al fin y al cabo todas esas cosas
también pasan en otros lugares.
Entonces, ¿Qué diantres hace que el problema
en Corea del Sur haya alcanzado tal magnitud?
Pues veréis, ya os adelanto, que algunas
cosas os van a chocar y mucho. Por un lado,
tenemos que la sociedad surcoreana es, quizás,
una de las sociedades más conservadoras y
tradicionales de entre todos los países desarrollados.
Y vale, sí, ya sé lo que estaréis pensando,
pero Alberto, si en esto de la natalidad,
las sociedades conservadoras suelen tener
ventaja, ¿no? Pues no, no siempre.
Uno de los problemas que tienen en el país
de la mañana tranquila es su forma extremadamente
puritana o tradicional de concebir la maternidad
y los modelos de familia. De hecho, virtualmente,
solo existe una familia: la que está formalmente
compuesta entre una mujer y un hombre. Y luego
los hijos, claro.
Todo lo que está fuera de este marco se queda
en la práctica fuera del sistema, y con ello
la sociedad surcoreana pierde un montón de
oportunidades para solucionar, o como mínimo
mitigar, su gran problema de falta de niños.
Pero como sé que este que he dicho os está
chocando e incluso alguno de vosotros estará
escandalizado, os vamos a dar datos y ejemplos
concretos. Fijaos.
(En Corea, solo el 2,9 % de los bebés que
nacieron en el año 2021 lo hicieron fuera
de un matrimonio, mientras que la media de
la OCDE es, atención del CUARENTA por ciento,
16 veces más. Casi un cuarenta por ciento
de los niños en Corea del Sur simplemente
no nacen.
Es decir, que la sociedad surcoreana no concibe
tener hijos si no existe de por medio un matrimonio
tradicional. Estar casados es requisito ineludible
para tener hijos. Y no, no es que religiosa
o socialmente sean muy diferentes o que tengan
más apetito por el matrimonio, que ya os
adelanto que no. Es una cuestión sobre todo
cultural.)
En el caso de las madres solteras, por ejemplo,
muchas se enfrentan al juicio de una sociedad
en la que el honor y el qué dirán tienen
todavía demasiado peso. Y, ¿qué queréis
que os diga? En Corea del Sur tener un hijo
fuera del matrimonio está muy mal visto.
Y no hablemos ya de familias del mismo sexo.
En general, en este país se consideran que
todas estas cosas son algo malo para los niños.
Y, no, lo siento, aunque el resto del mundo
desarrollado no parezca sumergido en el apocalipsis,
en este vídeo no vamos a entrar en esa cuestión,
aquí lo que nos importa es el impacto que
esto tiene en las tasas de natalidad.
El caso es que toda esta presión cultural
obliga a las mujeres a tomar una decisión:
buscar a toda costa un marido para poder tener
hijos, o desistir de la maternidad y centrarse
en ellas mismas y en sus carreras profesionales.
Y sí, eso es exactamente lo que muchas mujeres
están haciendo, optar por esta segunda opción.
Luego os contaremos con más detalle por qué.
Pero el caso es que al final cada vez menos
mujeres están dispuestas a tener descendencia,
lo que, lógicamente, contribuye a que la
tasa de natalidad esté por los suelos.
Pero, esperad un momento porque no todo son
tan malas noticias. Afortunadamente, la sociedad
también está cambiando y poco a poco cada
vez más gente acepta que la maternidad se
produzca fuera del matrimonio tradicional.
Por ejemplo, en los 10 años que transcurrieron
entre 2012 y 2022, la aceptación de la maternidad
estando soltera ha crecido más de 12 puntos,
de poco más del 22  a casi el 35 % de
los encuestados.
Claro que las instituciones públicas todavía
avanzan más lentas.
Por ejemplo, en la definición que hace la
Ley surcoreana de salud materno-infantil sobre
el término sub-fertilidad se hace referencia
explícita a una “pareja casada”. Es decir,
que no existe otra posibilidad para recibir
apoyo en tratamientos de fertilidad.
De una forma u otra, el sistema excluye a
las mujeres solteras del acceso a los tratamientos
de fertilidad o fecundación in vitro.
(Aún más, la Ley de Seguridad y Bioética
surcoreana dice que cualquiera que busque
realizar un tratamiento de fecundación in
vitro debe contar con el consentimiento de
su pareja.
O en otras palabras, que se da por hecho que
estos tratamientos son exclusivamente para
parejas, lo que significa que en Corea es
en la práctica imposible que una mujer por
sí sola pueda acceder a ellos.
Y no solo eso, aparte de lo que ya dice de
por sí la Ley, la Iglesia surcoreana también
se opone fervientemente a estas técnicas
para mujeres solteras. Y hablamos de un país
en el que la relación entre los políticos
y las congregaciones religiosas suele ser
muy estrecha.)
Y queridos amigos, amigas, todo esto cobra
todavía más importancia si tenemos en cuenta
otro de los problemas a los que las mujeres
jóvenes surcoreanas hoy no se quieren enfrentar.
Y es básicamente a los roles tradicionales
que todavía existen en la sociedad surcoreana
respecto a la maternidad y el matrimonio.
Digamos que las ambiciones profesionales y
personales de las mujeres jóvenes en este
país han cambiado mucho más rápido de lo
que lo ha hecho la percepción de su rol en
sociedad. Por ejemplo, es muy, pero que muy
frecuente que en Corea los hombres le dejen
a las mujeres toda la carga de criar a sus
hijos, a pesar de que estas trabajen.
En Corea del Sur los niños son cosas estrictamente
de mujeres… Y lógicamente eso no es fácil
de compatibilizar con la vida moderna y las
legítimas aspiraciones personales y profesionales
de cientos y cientos de miles, millones de
mujeres.
Es algo que os hemos dicho muchas veces en
VisualPolitik: las narrativas cuentan.
Y a ver, no, no estamos hablando del “heter
opatriarcado” ni de cosas por el estilo,
sino de unos roles sociales que en la inmensa
mayor parte de occidente han sido ya superados,
pero que no ha ocurrido lo mismo en Corea
del Sur, ni en Asia en general.
Y luego sí, por supuesto, también está
el tema de los salarios, el deseo de tener
carreras profesionales y las viviendas extremadamente
caras, algo de lo que ya os hemos hablado
en anteriores vídeos.
Pues bien, el caso es que la suma de todos
estos motivos han hecho que cada más mujeres
jóvenes tengan la sensación de que tanto
el matrimonio como la maternidad son una carga
innecesaria, más bien un problema para ellas
al que no tienen ninguna gana de enfrentarse.
¿Queréis un dato llamativo? De acuerdo a
un estudio realizado en 2020, el 42,5 %
de los surcoreanos en la treintena no están
casados, 13 puntos más que en 2010.
(Los romances se disparan en Corea del Sur,
pero el matrimonio ya no es el objetivo final
- The Japan Times)
De hecho, de todos los hogares que hay en
Corea del Sur, ni más ni menos que cuatro
de cada 10 están formados por una sola persona,
y en 2022 se registró el número más bajo
de matrimonios desde 1970, con menos de 192.000.
En Corea del Sur las mujeres jóvenes cada
vez tienen menos ganas de casarse y asumir
todo lo que ello conlleva en la cultura y
la sociedad de este país. Y ya habéis visto
que sin matrimonio tampoco hay niños, o al
menos hay muchos menos.
Pero aún hay más.
Por mucho que esto os pueda sorprender, existe
incluso un movimiento femenino conocido como
el de los cuatro noes: no a tener citas, no
a tener sexo con hombres, no al matrimonio
y no a tener hijos.
La familia tradicional es cada vez menos popular
entre los jóvenes de este país. Y ya habéis
visto que tal y como están montadas las cosas
eso tiene consecuencias.
Pero, llegados a este punto y ahora que ya
sabéis cuáles son las principales causas
de esta debacle demográfica, puede que muchos
os estéis haciendo una pregunta: ¿qué diablos
está haciendo el gobierno para tratar de
solucionar esta situación? ¿Acaso puede
hacer algo?
Pues bien, lo cierto es que sí, sí que han
hecho y siguen haciendo cosas. Pero podríamos
decir que… en fin, parece como si dieran
palos de ciego a la desesperada.
¿Queréis saber cuál es probablemente la
parte más divertida de toda esta historia?
Pues prestad mucha atención.
T2(MATANDO MOSCAS A CAÑONAZOS)
Os hago una pregunta, ¿y si os dijera que
Corea del Sur ha dilapidado 200.000 millones
de dólares en los últimos 16 años en políticas
para fomentar la natalidad, y, sin embargo,
no han conseguido absolutamente nada de nada?
200.000 millones de dólares después el número
de nacimientos está en mínimos históricos.
[Lo que por cierto supone todo un aviso a
navegantes, a tantos políticos que se piensan
que este tema se soluciona tirando de chequera]
Amigos, amigas, el estado surcoreano ha dilapidado
unos 12.500 millones de dólares cada año
en políticas de natalidad. Esto es más o
menos el presupuesto que un país como España
destina a defensa anualmente. Y como veis,
el resultado ha sido… ninguno.
¿Puede ser que Corea sea el ejemplo perfecto
de cómo la natalidad no se fomenta con dinero
público? Pues quizás sí, quizás estemos
ante el ejemplo más salvaje que podamos ver.
Pero es que lo peor de todo no es eso, lo
peor de todo es que el gobierno sigue optando
por esta vía a pesar de admitir que no funciona.
(31 agosto 2022: Corea triplicará los cheques
bebé después de batir su propio récord
con la tasa de fertilidad más baja del mundo
- Bloomberg)
Para que os hagáis una idea, el Presidente
Yoon ha anunciado que triplicaría el cheque
bebé que ya existía durante los primeros
dos años de vida del recién nacido.
Un incremento que supondrá pasar de los 300.000
wones que estableció el expresidente Moon
Jae In a 1 millón de wones, al cambio algo
más de 750 dólares cada mes.
Y no nos engañemos, el resultado seguramente
no cambie nada.
En los países ricos como Corea el tener o
no hijos tiene que ver más con motivos sociales
y culturales y no tanto con problemas económicos.
("Si el entorno es adecuado y las personas
se sienten protegidas y alentadas a tener
hijos, tendrán bebés incluso si se les dice
que no lo hagan. Los incentivos en dinero
por sí solos no pueden hacer mucho para impulsar
la natalidad". - Chung Ick-joong, profesor
de asistencia social en la Universidad Femenina
Ewha)
Claro que, lo cierto es que incluso esta medida
-probablemente tan inútil como la anterior-
sea mejor que otras ocurrencias disparatadas
que han tenido los políticos surcoreanos
para enfrentarse a este problema.
Algunas de ellas son tan locas que cualquiera
podría pensar que están desesperados dando
palos de ciego. ¿No nos creéis? ¿Pensáis
que estamos exagerando? Pues tomad nota.
(Una docena de legisladores presentaron la
propuesta de inundar el país de niñeras
extranjeras con sueldos por debajo del salario
mínimo. De hecho, la propuesta incluía que
no se aplicase el salario mínimo a las niñeras
extranjeras.
Esto es algo que ya se ha hecho en países
como Singapur bajo la excusa de que las condiciones
siguen siendo mucho mejores que en sus países
de origen. Pero sea como sea, es algo que
en Corea levantó muchas críticas.)
Luego también se ha propuesto eximir del
servicio militar obligatorio a los hombres
que tengan tres o más hijos antes de los
30 años.
El problema es los hombres son los únicos
que están obligados a hacer el servicio militar
y, ¿qué queréis qué os diga? Por muchos
hombres que estén dispuestos a librarse de
la molesta “mili” de esta manera, si no
hay mujeres dispuestas a tener hijos, eso
no sirve de nada.
Pero esperad un momento porque ahora viene
lo bueno de verdad.
Las dos cosas que os vamos a contar ahora
se hicieron realidad, no se trata de ninguna
broma. Fijaos.
(31 diciembre 2016: Corea del Sur retira una
web que mapea a las mujeres en edad reproductiva
Corea del Sur ha cerrado un sitio web del
gobierno que muestra el número de mujeres
de entre 15 y 49 años, en edad fértil, por
distritos y regiones después de una protesta
pública. [...] Los usuarios podían consultar
cuántas mujeres de esas edades residían
en su barrio durante los últimos 10 años.
- The Guardian)
[Tono irónico] Es como una especie de caravana
del amor pero en versión online e instada
por el gobierno… ¿No os parece brillante?...
En fin.
Pues si eso os ha llamado la atención, todavía
no habéis visto nada. En Corea hay gobiernos
locales que han estado subvencionando la “compra”
de esposas extranjeras. Sí, sí, tal y como
lo escucháis.
(19 febrero 2019: Subsidios locales fomentan
en Corea del Sur la 'compra de novias' extranjeras;
las novias de Uzbekistán son las 'más caras'
Más de 35 gobiernos municipales [...] han
implementado subsidios matrimoniales a los
hombres locales que se casan con novias extranjeras.)
Hablamos de toda una industria que ya tiene
unos cuantos años en Corea.
De hecho, incluso en el mismo Seúl hay establecimientos,
negocios, donde puedes ir, elegir una mujer
en un catálogo y, luego, tras desembolsar
una cantidad de dinero, estas empresas gestionan
que estas mujeres se venga desde su país
para casarse contigo. Lógicamente, no de
forma obligada… Pero sea como sea, es de
locos.
Corea del Sur es, junto con Taiwán, el país
asiático en el que más se lleva a cabo esta
práctica. Para algunos este es un claro ejemplo
de tráfico de personas, pero para otros no
es más que una intermediación como cualquiera
otra.
De hecho, este tipo de actividad tiene nombre
y apellido: se les llama brókers matrimoniales.
Y ojo, que hay casi 400 en todo el país
Y no sé, ¿qué queréis qué os diga? Consideraciones
morales aparte, quizás el que haya administraciones
públicas subvencionando estas operaciones
con hasta casi 10.000 dólares, sí que cruza
todos los límites. Y sí, eso es exactamente
lo que algunos municipios hacen.
¿El resultado? En este gráfico lo podéis
ver perfectamente.
Sea como sea, ya lo habéis visto, Corea del
Sur tiene un problema de natalidad tan grave
que puede poner al propio país en el camino
de su propia extinción.
Un problema que, lejos de mejorar, no hace
más que ir a peor. Cada vez más mujeres
rechazan la maternidad y el matrimonio. Y
eso en una sociedad y bajo unas instituciones
que todavía son incapaces de aceptar otros
tipos de maternidad o roles y adaptar las
políticas públicas es un problema grave.
Pero, llegados hasta aquí, el turno es para
ti. ¿Crees que Corea del Sur podría revertir
su gran problema demográfico con otro tipo
de políticas públicas? ¿Ha fracasado el
viejo modelo de creer que para tener hijos
solo hace falta regalar más y más dinero?
¿Qué opináis de las propuestas y las políticas
que están impulsando en Corea para lograr
que nazcan más niños?
Déjanos tu opinión aquí abajo, en los comentarios.
Y recuerda, si te ha gustado este vídeo no
te olvides de darle a like, suscribirte a
nuestro canal y darle a la campanita para
no perderte ninguna novedad que esté por
llegar.
Ah, y muy importante, si quieres ayudarnos
a seguir creciendo y mejorando, puedes sumarte
a nuestra comunidad en Patreon con la que
recibirán contenidos exclusivos. Os dejamos
el link en la descripción.
Una vez más, muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.